acquire today at the ashton gate
vaccination center in bristol
but it's been a strong few days for the
uk vaccine program
and crucially ministers say supplies of
vaccine
will keep on coming i'm confident we'll
meet our mid-february target of the top
four cohorts
i'm also confident because i have enough
line of sight
of uh the deliveries that are coming
through that will also meet the one to
nine
cohorts by may and we'll say more about
that
next week when we hit the first target i
hope uh that all goes well
it's a tough target by the way it is a
tough target
as this chart shows more than 12
million people have now been given their
first dose of the vaccine
but inconsistent supply has meant
delivery has been
up and down and the government is not
that far above the daily rate required
to meet its target of 15 million vaccine
offers
by february the 15th in bristol
the big queue was at the surge testing
center
used to track the variant first
identified in south africa
new studies suggest existing vaccines
may stop this variant causing serious
harm
but not stop it spreading what we're
seeing from other vaccine developers
is that they have a reduction in
efficacy against some of the variant
viruses
and what that is looking like is that
we may not be reducing the total number
of cases
but there's still protection in that
case against
deaths hospitalizations and severe
disease work is already underway on a
second generation vaccine
but the possibility of ongoing
transmission is
one reason why the vaccine minister
pushed back
against the idea of a vaccine passport
if other countries obviously
require some form of proof
then you can ask your gp because your gp
will hold the record
and of course uh that will then be able
to be used as
your proof that you've had the vaccine
but we are not planning to have a
passport in the uk i just want to repeat
that because i've had a lot of it
on my social media all this means that
the vaccine might not get rid of covert
19 once and for all
but it's still our best way out of the
pandemic
and every jab does give the most
vulnerable protection
against the worst effects of the virus
roland manthop sky news